alors si l'époque vous avez ce château
de 18 pièces 50 hectares 300 moutons
faire écouter tout votre pognon ce
recueil tout mon pognon ouais ouais les
experts comptables visaient bandits dans
julia quand est-ce que c'est fini les
moutons donc oui c'est ça me semble
coûter tout d'ailleurs
je me suis toujours demandé comment
faisaient les jeunes agriculteurs pour
vivre may cry 2 et mener leur
exploitation puisque moi tout mon argent
le chanteur passait là dedans
alors j'ai dit que vous livrez beaucoup
plus qu'avant et c'est vrai parce que
vous parlez de virginie donc cesser pas
c'est pas vieux virginie 1 c'est et vous
avouer que l'équitation en fait ça vous
saoule quoi après plus tôt elle est
complète et toutes étaient faits dès
qu'on fait et bien envoyé lé là c'est un
grand talent et de faire chier
il me dit maintenant
ouais et c'est à dire que je crois que
ce qui a changé avec canton finalement
jeu depuis l'âge de 20 ans que je le
veuille ou non je vis avec le public
moi ce que je me suis toujours dit c'est
tant que ça ne me porte pas au fond de
moi même c'est à dire la barrière qu'on
a tous au fond de nous je me suis tant
que ce que que ça que je ne braque pas
que ça ne me fait pas du mal que je peux
encore me regarder dans la glace etc
avoir l'air à peu près digne en faisant
ça je peux le donner